150 vaches et 350 chèvre la ferme de la
tramblais situe à la boissière école
élèves c'est bête depuis 1967 l'ensemble
des étapes de production s'effectue
directement sur place la ferme fabrique
ses propres aux fromages et yaourts à
partir du lait de ces animaux et dispose
d'une boutique pour vendre ses produits
elle a également d'autres modes de
distribution on travaille
sur une clientèle locale de magasins en
circuits courts des magasins de
producteurs on travaille également
auprès des grandes surfaces
mais uniquement en ile de france est
toujours dans ce même esprit de circuits
courts et de circuit local le circuit
court fait donc recettes la ferme de la
tramblais participe également au salon
de paris fermée depuis 2018 un marché de
producteurs itinérant pour toucher une
plus grande clientèle effectivement
c'est c'est un moyen de communication à
travers une association qui existe
depuis assez longtemps mais c'est
également le moyen de de présenter nos
produits à des consommateurs direct et
non plus en passant par des
intermédiaires et le week-end prochain
le 17 18 et 19 septembre le site
agricole accueillera une trentaine
d'exposants pour pari fermier c'est
vraiment dans nos moeurs on en profite
pour ouvrir nos portes au public parce
que nous ne sommes pas ouverts toute
l'année au public juste un petit espace
qui est dédié à une boutique de la ferme
selon l'institut de sondage kantar en
2020 64% des français ont consommé des
produits issus des circuits courts au
moins une fois par mois